qui est certain c'est quand on a
constaté en 2018 une augmentation plus
que significatif des affaires qui ont
été traitée par la jirs ce de fort de
france en matière de criminalité
organisée
très concrètement ça veut dire que en
l'occurrence jamais nous n'avions eu une
activité aussi forte en matière de lutte
contre la grande criminalité organisée
ici en martinique alors à cela il y à il
ya au moins trois explications
la première de ces explications c'est
que cette hausse on doit pouvoir la
mettre en corrélation avec
l'augmentation indéniable
malheureusement au cours des deux
dernières années de la production de
cocaïne en amérique du sud
or cette production de cocaïne dans
suite être écoulés et les poly
consommateurs ne sont pas les pays
producteurs en l'occurrence perry
consommateurs c'est essentiellement
l'amérique du nord et l'europe
et on sait parfaitement que depuis fort
longtemps cette zone des antilles
constitue un axe stratégique
géographique majeure et c'est la raison
pour laquelle nous avons plus de dossier
de cette nature
le deuxième élément également c'est que
face à cette augmentation igman
également une augmentation des moyens de
l'état qui ont été mises en oeuvre pour
lutter contre ce phénomène une
augmentation de 25% de ses effectifs de
la peau de la police judiciaire la
création d'une antenne de l'os artis en
cayenne la création d'une d'un service
du sndj le service national des douanes
judiciaires en septembre dernier ici en
martinique et à partir du moment où vous
avez plus de moyens ainsi pour lutter
contre ce phénomène et bien il ya plus
de dossiers qui sont présentés à la
justice
et puis dernier élément également c'est
qu'il ya eu également une véritable
volonté de politique pénale qui est de
lutter dans ce cadre-là pas seulement au
niveau ici la martinique mais il faut
quand même le rappeler la juridiction
interrégionale spécialisée de
fort-de-france l'agir de fort de france
a une compétence sur l'ensemble de la
zone antilles guyane depuis saint martin
jusque
là jusque là la guyane en passant par
saint barthélemy la guadeloupe ainsi que
l'île naturellement la martinique et en
l'occurrence et bien nous avons été
beaucoup plus nous avons beaucoup plus
pris de dossiers concernant cette zone
guadeloupéen et sept zones de guyane et
ce qui là aussi expliquent cette
augmentation des affaires est ce que
vous devez faire face à l'ingéniosité de
ceux qui qui créent ces flux de trafic
de drogue est ce que nous sommes à la
hauteur
l'itie aux antilles françaises ici en
guyane est-ce que nous sommes à la
hauteur de tels enjeux de tels chalenge
de tels défis technologiques souvent
c'est vrai que c'est une véritable
question ce qui est ce qui est certain
c'est qu'il y a quand même je crois un
véritable professionnalisme des
enquêteurs qui travaillent dans ce
domaine et ainsi que des magistrats
instructeurs et des magistrats du
parquet qui travaillent dans la lutte
contre ce phénomène là qui demande une
compétence un cru qui demande une
parfaite connaissance des techniques
spéciales denquête qui demande également
une véritable d'être imaginatif dans les
moyens de lutte et moi qui le voit au
quotidien je peux vous assurer qu'il ya
ya ya beaucoup de talent dans cette
équipe qui dans ces équipes qui luttent
contre ce type de phénomène